et ouais surprise bande de sales on ne
sait pas ce music est là aujourd'hui on
a pris les rênes
allez on est là pour toi sur youtube
quelques français vous êtes tous là à
gagner de l'argent en faisant des vidéos
de merde vous criez là avec des ouvriers
c'est drôle non tu cries aussi je suis
narbonne hockey du coup on va toujours
une chez un parent ok c'est vrai un et
make a plus de pub sursis fringues et
même que sur tsa oh tu viens tu ta vidéo
comme une herbe bas nous non plus am j
med
c'est marrant on dire été supris ans
mais avec moins de cheveux d'accord on
sait pas s'être qu'unibail 28 ans son
style l objet d'art en continu sur
squeeze et squeeze atr ton corps on
dirait une canne à pêche est le blédard
j'avais voté sur les miniatures qu'on
dirait que chez toi t'as pas de miroir
est le plus bas est je crois renoul se
sont inspirés ton trop pour faire le
toit panoramique du scénic qui parce
qu'on peut tuer piller panoramique
multiples et commet trop brouillons mon
pote ed simons chef ya plus de meuf
sûreté miniature que sur un site porno
veulent mais parce que je crois parce
que tu as tes muscles et à l'inde aux
enfants de cerfs-volants sai et
personnes valides étaient placés à
thibault et ya plus de meuf c'était quoi
ta vanne pourrie là sur les protéines
c'est à quel niveau
apparemment mon avant-bras y fait la
taille de la cuisse ou squeeze bled mais
ces matches là du coup c'est pas un tel
bâtiment rock et un mix mtt sur
tellement [ __ ] clic que je sais plus
si je suis sur youtube ou sur melty
intérieur hamilton attend d'ailleurs
fait ils sont tellement [ __ ] clic que
dans le milieu depuis ta clique ont
dicté et ils sont un mix est bon et
normal pour parler comme ça puisque
marwijk n'est pas passée que sont pas
trop prévisible par contre normale tu as
ndour et on filme pas très normal
activity fo est normal tu sais quoi
et la dernière fois
t'as fait quoi normal il tapait fort est
certain je suis envoyé plein de messages
et non un mois je crois que c'est parce
que david lafarge l'apple app la
dégustation
c'est pour ça que joueur du grenier il
avait grillé plus rien à manger mais si
tu attendais pas et même offerte a pas
donné la météo hier ils avaient prévu un
ouragan dans moi j'ai vu en fait j'étais
marqué 20 degrés avec un vent de faire
mayotte comme on ferme ta gueule l appui
de lafarge veut pas déguster là on
dirait les engage tous les acteurs en
ouvrant des boosts a troqué mon frère
boulic brûlis qu elle invite la trace
pokémon des vidéos pour qui monet pour
moi vu tes vidéos d'excitation tu
devrais appeler david lafarge
dégustation poèmes et services a fait
part plus de cheveux sur ton épaule que
sur ton crâne est d'ailleurs tov son
épaule elle est venue coiffer cochrane
sait qui est le phénix tu penses qu'à
phoenix renaît de ses cendres même à 300
degrés si ces faits un masque à la
cannelle ah ben ouais ouais c'est pas
noël tu serais pas tout ça avec eux
s'ils font donc de bergerac bien
elle a beau y stocke samecki des vidéos
sur youtube avait pas quitter numéro un
j'en connais pas j'ai regardé sur google
google connaît pas mais il est effarant
sur cherche communautés non jeu
battlefield tech
avant tu campes est en taule of duty
maintenant tu comme en vrai tu fais pour
faire un blog hôtels en 10 ans avec des
jumelles on vous regarde pire c'est pas
du jeu
elle est ce soir que de gagner au loto
voir antoine l'année à sortir une
nouvelle vidéo et seule la frite mon cas
c'est une quête secondaire non non je
ferme il ya quatre ans mais j'ai vu une
chaîne qui s'appelle strache il ya
peut-être surtout émis nature spa
taschen la machine ça c'est juste une
technique pour faire plus de vie
d'accord elle a sa six cordes un mec il
avait des sous pour acheter qu'un jour
il a choisi gta 5 il a vu le
rentabiliser pourtant de triomphe la
mecque à la fois je tombe sur une vidéo
secrète de studio bungie
bonjour cadix comment ça va bonjour
qu'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
calysto expliqua qu on va faire un peu
de toboggans c'est parti on n'y va
jamais au samu et ce qu'alice eve ou
tout seul mon gars des kings ok go tout
seul ah c'est pas un mec qui a monté un
collectif avec alger atomique
ils ont décidé de ne pas faire des
vidéos aller au bout et notamment
malcolm et apparemment il a dit seles
elle m'a appelé hier elle m'a dit ed dia
malcolm euro mes cheveux et squeeze
talent rare d'un tatouage comptait
sortir vers une fils de [ __ ] c'est tout
le monde ne voulait pas être méchant s
ils voulaient réponse alessi répondait à
nous les rageux on s'emballe écho à la
bombe nucléaire est lâchée sur le guen
c'est à toi tu as trouvé sur une vidéo
de deux mecs qui te lâche tout le
youtube game français mieux maintenant
mais avec moi